i'll always have love in my heart for
georgie there's a flame that's lit
and you know
in life everybody has relationship you
know issues and i would always
just want to make
it right i'm nervous about meeting
georgie i don't know what i'm
about to walk into congratulations on
season three that's a big accomplishment
thank you
when you first signed on to do the show
did you expect for it to go this far you
know i
really feel stacey and i have been on
this journey for a long time and we're
really really proud and excited to you
know be a part of the 90 day universe
when i watched the trailer i saw you two
walking out and i was just like did they
ever like when you were younger did you
ever imagine that one day we're gonna
have our own show
actually yeah
growing up when we were younger people
used to stop us all the time we want to
take pictures of us and we were kind of
like little you know tourist attractions
and i and i feel like it kind of stemmed
from a younger age and we always were
meant for tv i think yeah well let's get
into what we're gonna see this season
darcy
you're reuniting with your ex-fiance
georgie
georgie he's been texting me
and he wants me to meet him in new york
you're not gonna go are you
you went against your family's wishes
traveling to go meet with him why did
you decide that that was the best
decision
you know for me obviously you guys saw
on you know the last season you know the
breakup the transformation that i've
gone through in turkey i was very
empowered and strong during that time
felt free and i wasn't getting what i
deserved in that relationship and i
stood strong and
you know breakups aren't always easy you
guys know i always wear my heart on my
sleeve
but at the end of the day you know
there's
a flame that's still lit and i think you
guys are definitely gonna see you know
all the challenges that george and i go
through on this journey together in our
relationship and you know the first
episode's definitely gonna show a lot of
that so well stacy were you surprised
when she decided to go
um
no not really because i know that her
relationship with georgie was
you know there was a lot of love there
and even though they had ups and downs a
lot i know you know
she wanted it to work and
whatever makes darcy happy i'm happy and
at the bottom line is our family just
wants darcy happy well i know you can't
tell us much darcy but what can you
tease about that conversation with
georgie
i remember that day and you know my
heart was beating i was feeling all the
emotions i was
you know anticipating it and it felt
like it was the right thing for me to do
you know obviously the breakup happened
in turkey it was over the phone i just
felt like i needed to see him face to
face and really talk about things
firsthand you know and really dive in
deep and also let him know what i was
going to tolerate and what i wasn't
going to tolerate in the relationship
and you know i was owning that own
accountability for myself and it made me
feel more empowered and strong to be
able to meet him in person i didn't feel
like it was
something bad i thought it was you know
something positive in a sense and you
guys will definitely see
you know what happens that day
well i understand that we have to wait
to see the status of your relationship
but can you at least tell us this do you
still love him do you still love georgie
you know in this relationship
you know have a lot of love he had a lot
of love to give
i think you know in relationships you
have to be on the same page at the same
time have the same
themes visions and you know i just
really wanted us to both be transparent
in our feelings and where we saw the
relationship going i didn't want to
waste his time or my time
and
you know
the love we have for each other you know
we'll be there there's a flame that's
lit
and you know
in life everybody has relationship you
know issues and i would always
just want to make
it right
yeah
well i'm getting the gist that things
might have worked out because the flame
is still lit but we're not gonna we're
not gonna get too much into that i do
have a question about his ex-wife though
we saw you meet up with her last season
she told you that they're still legally
married i'm confused are you guys still
married unfortunately i guess is that
still the case
no i don't believe that's still the case
um you know stacy and i met octavia in
virginia and for me it was
you know an empowering thing as well i
didn't think it was like a basking
session we didn't go there to
dig up you know dirt i just wanted to
understand his relationship with her so
i could understand what i was going
through in mine and if that brought any
sort of clarity and confirmations for
what i was feeling in my relationship
that's what the purpose served she's an
amazing woman
um she had a positive attitude uh what
they dealt with their relationship was
different than what i've dealt with so
you know i mean
i i never really saw it as a negative
thing um i know some people thought well
why would you go to the ex but you know
i just i really wanted to get to know
him on a deeper level from other
people's perspective as well because he
wasn't as open as i wanted him to be at
times and it just felt like the right
thing to do
[Music]
stacy we're gonna see you and florian
plan your dream wedding which i'm super
excited about i'm gonna say yes to the
dress girl i love anything when it comes
to weddings but you also say that you're
getting a taste of his jealous side or
you got a taste of his jealous side what
can you tell us about that
um you know four and i have been
together seven years and we've been
through a lot good bad
and you know there's been times even
in the beginning of the relationship
where you know he's had a little jealous
side you know um
i never really thought too deep into it
because in a weird way i kind of was
like oh wow he's really into me you know
jealous but it was never like harmful
jealous it was it was just you know
it's kind of difficult you know to
explain but
i i know he never really meant it like
in a in a bad way but yeah he definitely
has a jealous side and you guys will see
see that come out more okay
well we're also going to see you to
expand your business you're entering
your clothing line into miami swim week
something that's interesting about you
too is that you're definitely boss women
that's clear but sometimes your
professional lives are overshadowed by
your love lives does that ever make you
feel some type of way
you know i think stacy and i work really
hard at what we do house of 11 started
11 years ago and none of our brother
michael
um passed away from a very very rare
form of cancer so we're very
um
you know close to this company and like
our baby it's like our baby we'll never
give it up you know we we're on a
mission for it so we strive very hard
for it but there are times that our
relationship our personal lives get
involved with that we love love we love
love
i'm a libra too oh my god i understand
yeah and just you know because we have a
fashion brand you know we're expanding
into home goods and you know many other
things young men's women's teens um
beauty it's just you know we we like to
involve our partners with that as well
you know we like to be able to plan our
future and see the bigger vision as well
so sometimes it gets a little
complicated
but in the end you know we'll never give
up on house of eleven and you know we
know we deserve love in the end and we
know we deserve to be successful and
you know we're we're excited
so basically what it sounds like you're
saying is that it it all works together
yeah although people might
some people might know you just for your
complicated love lives but it works with
your business as well and elevating that
it does it just works for stacey and i
and the partners that we have we need
somebody that stands understands us and
is willing to go along on this ride with
us in this journey as long as they're
living their own life as well right you
know we can't have partners that want to
break us apart or break up our vision
right or sabotage something that we're
working hard to do you know out of fear
or jealousy or just yeah
we're boss baits at heart and yeah we're
on a mission and we're not gonna stop
you know if they want to come for the
ride
be our guest
aiko has been so disciplined and so
focused on this pageant i'm really proud
of her we're gonna see you go on a ride
with your daughter her pageant you're
turning into a pageant mom this season
what can you tease about that experience
how how was it for you
you know uh seeing annika go to mission
connecticut was one of the most amazing
moments for me to see her i'm so proud
of her and aspen they actually they both
got asked to do the pageant um aspen
didn't want to compete against dynaco
you know she just wanted tonica to have
her moment and then maybe she'll do it
eventually but just so proud that she
was able to have grace poised confidence
and really get to know herself on a
deeper level and not fear anything um so
proud of her so i will cheer her on like
a pageant mom stage mom whatever you
want to call it and then some because
she deserves to be praised and loved and
you know acknowledged for all the hard
work and dedication she put into it she
really did
i love that
amazing job
yeah well as a mother of two daughters
what is something that you want them to
know when it comes to beauty and
confidence
yeah as a mom you know i have two
amazing beautiful daughters they're
smart they're level-headed they have you
know amazing future ahead and i just
want them to always you know love
themselves from the inside out know
their worth know that they can
accomplish anything they put their mind
to
never settle for anything less don't let
anyone say you can't do something
because you can that's one thing our
brother taught us before he passed he
was like go out and do whatever your
heart desires because you will make it
never let anyone say you can't do
something never let anyone take you down
i want them to know to rise to the top
of that mountain because they're going
to get there
yes
brother he's preaching to all of us
right now
i have to ask this one question before i
let you go because it was a shock to me
darcy your ex jesse
dating tim's ex jennifer on the single
life i know i know i know but what was
your initial reaction to that how do you
feel about it it wasn't surprised
that's jesse's style and of course i had
to be a past cast member as well from
you know before 90 days as well um i
loved him i
you know
respect jennifer you know it's their
life as long as they're happy and love
and and doing it you know for real and
not for a show or anything like that i
think it's great you know more power to
them
here we are
better than ever